El fútbol es como las salchichas, si de verdad te
gusta es mejor no saber cómo se hace
Efectivamente este mes empieza la Eurocopa 2016 y con
ella millones de personas sacarán el
cuñado que llevan dentro
para decir: "si es que no sudan la camiseta
con lo que ganan, parece mentira, pasarán
hambre... ******
Lo cierto es que el fútbol mueve
millones de euros, el sueldo de gente
como Cristiano Ronaldo o Messi dejaría a Ana Patricia Botín, la presidenta del
Banco Santander, a la altura de una pobre
mileurista. ¿Y de dónde viene todo este
dinero? Pues principalmente de la
publicidad, empresas como Adidas pagan la
friolera de 43 millones de euros al Real
Madrid solamente para que ponga su
logotipo en las camisetas de los
jugadores. Y os preguntaréis, ¿pero de verdad
merece la pena gastarse tantísimo
dinero en que tu logotipo aparezca en
un estadio o en una camiseta?
La respuesta os va a dejar helados porque
una consultora de marketing que se llama
RadiumOne ha hecho una encuesta en la
que han preguntado a mil británicos si
reconocían los logotipos de los
sponsors de la eurocopa.
Es decir, les ponía varios logos de
empresas y les preguntaban si sabían
reconocer cuáles estaban patrocinando
la Eurocopa.
"Orange, Hisense o Hyundai -todos ellos
patrocinadores oficiales-
fueron reconocidos únicamente por un
1% de la gente"
Pero la cosa no
se queda aquí porque si seguimos
leyendo la noticia
encontramos cosas como ésta:
"Mastercard, Heineken, Barclays y Budweiser pese a no
ser patrocinadores estuvieron entre las
diez marcas más reconocidas"
O sea, que Hyundai ha pagado una millonada para que
luego el mérito se lo lleve Heineken
sin pagar un duro.
¡Bienvenidos al mundo de la publicidad!
Sin embargo, y pese a todo esto, las
empresas siguen invirtiendo muchísimo
dinero en patrocinios deportivos
de hecho la UEFA va a sacar un beneficio
por patrocinios dos veces mayor en esta
Eurocopa que en la del año 2012. Y os
preguntaréis, ¿qué hacemos en VisualPolitik
hablándoos de fútbol. ¿Qué tiene
que ver el fútbol con la política? Pues
mis queridos amigos,
mucho, tiene mucho que ver. De hecho la
lista de patrocinadores de esta Eurocopa
es el lienzo perfecto para entender
dónde está la economía mundial
hoy en día. Mirad, ésta es la lista de
sponsors oficiales de este año, y aquí
al lado he puesto la del año 1996, es
decir, hace dos décadas. ¿Notáis alguna
diferencia?
Bueno, antes de ver las diferencias vamos
a ver los
parecidos, porque en ambos casos
encontramos dos logos el de McDonald's y
el de Coca-Cola. Son dos empresas que
llevan años patrocinando todos los
patrocinable, que siempre están ahí y
que tienen muy buena salud. Son algo así
como el Jordi Hurtado de la economía.
Pero hasta aquí los parecidos,
ahora vamos a las diferencias porque si
os dais cuenta en el año 96 había tres
empresas japonesas que patrocinaban la
Eurocopa en aquella época
Japón era una potencia industrial que le
estaba haciendo la competencia al
mismísimo Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo hoy las empresas niponas han
desaparecido del mapa de los patrocinios,
y con que en la última década
el crecimiento económico de Japón se
ha estancado por supuesto que Japón
sigue siendo un país rico con empresas
muy potentes: ahí está Sony, ahí está
Toyota pero todas ellas fueron
creadas en los años 70-80 y casi no han
innovado desde entonces. Por ejemplo, los
primeros modelos de smartphone fueron la
blackberry y el iphone.
Luego llegó Sony y sacó su propia
versión con tecnología punta y de
muy buena calidad pero que va a rebufo
de lo que han creado los americanos en
este caso, y si os dais cuenta, casi todas
las empresas japonesas están yendo a
rebufo de otras: no lideran. Es más,  ¿conocéis alguno o alguna empresa japonesa
famosa que se haya creado en los últimos
años?
Todo esto tiene su reflejo en las
figuras macroeconómicas y por supuesto
también en la Eurocopa. Pero vamos a
volver a la lista de patrocinadores,
porque si bien Japón se ha marchado han
aparecido otros distintos como Corea del
Sur, China, Turquía o Azerbaiyán. SOCAR es la petrolera del gobierno de
azerbaiyán, un país que casi nadie
seríamos capaces de colocar en un mapa
que tiene 10 millones de habitantes y un
montón de gas y de petróleo. Llevan
varios años negociando con la Unión
Europea la construcción de un gasoducto
que iría por aquí.
En principio la idea es muy buena para
los europeos porque tendríamos otro
proveedor de gas que reduciría nuestra
dependencia de países como Rusia o
Argelia. ¿Problema? Que Azerbaiyán es una
de las dictaduras más salvajes del
mundo, no sólo persiguen a los que
critican al gobierno sino que también
meten en la cárcel a sus familiares.
(Voz en off): "En julio de 2015
la policía arrestó a tres familiares
de Ganimat Zahid, un periodista en el  exilio
que dirige una televisión en Turquía".
La dictadura de Azerbaiyán necesita
lavar su imagen de cara a la opinión
pública europea.
¿Y qué mejor manera de hacerlo que
financiando el fútbol? Por eso hace
años veíamos el logotipo de
Azerbaiyán en las camisetas del
Atlético de Madrid y ahora nos vamos a
cansar de ver el logotipo de SOCAR en
todas partes durante la Eurocopa 2016.
Pero esperad porque todavía tenemos
logotipos más interesantes:
ahí está el de Turkish Airlines,
nos hemos acostumbrado ya a ver anuncios
de Turkish Airlines por todas partes
tanto que ya nos hemos olvidado de lo
que significa, pero imaginaros que hace
20 años nos hubieran dicho que una
empresa turca
va a ser una de las aerolíneas más
importantes del mundo. En el año 2003
Turkish Airlines era una aerolínea sin
pena ni gloria que no la conocía nadie.
Diez años más tarde ganaba el doble de
dinero que Iberia y es el mascarón de
proa de un país que se está
convirtiendo en la China de Europa. Pero
sin duda alguna el logotipo más
interesante de todos es éste: el de Hisense.
Probablemente muy poquitos conozcáis a Hisense pero muchos de
vosotros tengáis algún televisor de
ellos y no lo sepáis. Hisense nació como un
mero suministrador de componentes para
otros fabricantes tan conocidos como
Hitachi o Sharp.
Durante años este tipo de empresas al
carecer de marca propia no tenían que
invertir grandes sumas de dinero en
publicidad ni preocuparse del cliente
minorista, básicamente basaban su valor
en fabricar componentes para otras
compañías.
Por eso muchos de los routers y de los
modems que nos regalaba Telefónica y
Vodafone en España estaban fabricados
por Huawei pero logo ni siquiera
aparecía en la caja lo tenías que
abrir el cacharro y ver dentro estaba en
pequeñito "hecho por Huawei". Sin embargo con el
tiempo se han dado cuenta de que
también pueden competir ofreciendo
productos de calidad y diferenciados.
La pionera en esta tendencia fue Huawei que ya
lleva años sacando móviles con su
propia marca, buenos anuncios y buena
calidad y parece que Hisense está
siguiendo la misma estela.
Esto no es ninguna tontería y marca
un antes y un después en la economía
china. Hasta ahora les veíamos como
fabricantes de productos cutres pero
muy baratos, ahora están empezando a
sacar bienes de muy alta calidad con su
propia marca y, por supuesto, su propia publicidad. En el futuro vamos a ver muchas más
empresas chinas inundando los mercados
europeos.
por eso el hecho de que Hisense esté
patrocinando la Eurocopa significa que
se lo están tomando muy en serio.
Así que si lo miramos con perspectiva,
el fútbol nos ofrece una foto fija de
lo que es la globalización hoy en día.
Hace 20 años el mercado estaba dominado
por Estados Unidos, Europa y Japón.
Ahora hay nuevos países como China o
Turquía que están compitiendo en
igualdad de condiciones con las empresas
americanas. Así que la pregunta es, ¿cómo
será la lista de patrocinadores de la Eurocopa del 2036?
¿Veremos ya alguna empresa africana? Podéis dejarme vuestras respuestas en
los comentarios.
Como siempre los que queráis
profundizar más en este tema
encontraréis varios links en la
descripción y si os ha gustado este
vídeo darle a like y suscribiros al
canal si todavía no lo habéis hecho.
Nos vemos en el próximo vídeo,
¡un abrazo y hasta pronto!